in september of this year more than 4.4
million people in the u.s quit their
jobs that's around 3
of the entire workforce and this number
expands back to 20 million people if
measured back to april of 2021 i'm sure
you've heard we're in an era called the
great resignation where people are
quitting their jobs in droves
so in this video we're going to explore
why this is happening
what it means for us moving forward and
how we as workers can learn from this so
that we can design a better future for
ourselves
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dani and i am
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and also some
tools and strategies that can help us
have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture so i left two
jobs in the last two years once just
before the pandemic and one during the
pandemic and throughout the past few
years i've been thinking a lot about my
relationship with work how i want to
spend my time
and the value of my time so just in the
last two years several things happened
in my life i became a registered
architect i gained more experience and i
became more confident in my abilities
i paid off my student loans and actually
started to
have some savings and i started
investing some money
and i also had a lot of time
spent alone
and to be completely honest i probably
wouldn't have been able to leave my jobs
like this if it weren't for these
factors in fact the highest levels of
resignations seem to be amongst the
mid-career or
almost mid-career employees or basically
people who have experience in their
field but haven't really built long-term
foundations in one place to really feel
like they're losing something
when they leave but even if you're not
at the midpoint of your career i think
there's a lot of things you could take
away from this because this is not just
a phase
this is a
huge change in the way that people are
looking at their work
and their relationship with work
and i really believe this is going to
transform many industries in the
following years
so let's dig a little bit into why this
is happening people seem to be leaving
their jobs for three main reasons either
to move to a different company
or to change industries
or to start their own businesses in case
you're watching this video from the
future 2020
is the time when the pandemic started
and people were forced to work from home
with the amount of time people were
spending at home i think we started
looking at our lives in a different
perspective
and we really started reassessing our
values personally i really realize the
joy of spending time with friends and
family and the joy of giving time to
myself and just like doing little things
that nourish my soul and make me happy
and i think we also realize that life is
really short and for a few period of
months at the start of the pandemic we
had no freaking idea what was going to
happen
and i think people realize that life is
too short to be doing something that
doesn't bring us happiness or meaning
for a lot of people i guess that was
their jobs i think another side to this
is the slight detachment of work from
self-worth i think especially for
architects this is a bit of a pain point
because we
attach our values so intimately to our
work and you know the industry is kind
of designed that way
like
with the whole practice of judging a
person by their portfolio
um but i think in these past few years
we as we assessed our values
and um probably by having reduced
contact with society and societal
pressures
i feel like people are starting to
detach their value from their work i
have a colleague who recently left and
went to another firm
and when she told me where she was going
honestly i was a little bit shocked and
i thought it was a little bit strange
because i felt like it was a little bit
of a step down for her that firm wasn't
doing incredibly exciting work and it
was just like very conventional
architecture
but the more i thought about it it made
sense
she's getting better pay
better work-life balance and you know
that was her trade-off in the book
[ __ ] jobs by david graber
he talks about how the idea of
work as a source of value
is actually a pretty recent idea
and it really started with like
philosophers like john locke and
the puritan ideologies which basically
claimed that like suffering
endured by the working classes
is noble and virtuous that mindset has
been passed down to us
and on top of that in modern society our
jobs basically support our
very consumerist patterns of living
and we justify the daily dullness of
work because it fulfills our consumerist
desires
where we need to buy things we don't
really need
to climb the social ladder which in
itself is not real and i think that's
the other thing that's happened during
the pandemic our habits of consumption
have changed we're not really going out
as much we're not buying as much
and we don't need to spend as much
and all of a sudden you realize like
okay that's where all my money was going
the other reason is burnout
working from home blurred the lines
between people's work and personal lives
and a lot of people ended up working
more than there are a lot of number of
hours because for a lot of companies the
amount of work and deadlines didn't
change in fact a lot of the burden of
this shift to working from home fell on
the employees especially for visual
communicators like architects
in order to communicate effectively we
we had to produce more presentations and
more drawings but instead of having a
reduced workload a lot of that fell on
the employees to have to do the extra
work and put in the extra hours i think
really uh depending on how the firms
handled it this pandemic really exposed
a lot of the floss in the management of
the business also having to keep up
productivity while being isolated at
home is really hard because you're not
really getting the benefit of vibing off
of the energy of the office or your
colleagues which i think has led to
a questioning of the work culture
for me
culture is really important
it's a really important factor in my
work environment
i like having company outings and friday
night beers and building rapport with my
colleagues because
working with people that i like
helps me enjoy my work and it keeps me
invested in the company but the switch
to working from home
has really opened my eyes to how much
time i could save
and how much more productive i could be
from working from home
which directly gives me more time for
myself i think more and more people are
willing to trade that work culture for
better work-life balance
and for more control over their work
hours and schedules as the pandemic
starts to slow down some offices have
made it mandatory to go back to fully
working in the office but a lot of
employees have been really turned off by
this
because
we're i mean we've already demonstrated
for the past two years that we can work
independently and i think this just
shows a lot of it shows a lack of trust
and a lack of flexibility in the company
so i think this is gonna be a real
downside to companies that are enforcing
this the fourth reason is that we are in
the golden age of entrepreneurship
it's easier to start a business now than
ever since january to october this year
there were 4.7 million business
applications just in the us
which was a 34 increase from that same
time in 2019 first of all the cost of
failure is close to zero there's
multiple sources of capital that you
could tap into cost of testing out an
idea is super cheap you can literally
just ask a question to twitter or
facebook or instagram and with platforms
like fiverr and upwork it's so easy to
hire freelancers also there's a massive
amount of content and communities for
entrepreneurs
more than ever before any person can
basically start their own thing as long
as you're providing good value and good
content so if you've been working till
the point of burnout and you're not so
attached to your job
like why would i spend
the time to build someone else's
business when i can spend the time to
build my own
so what this means is that for the first
time in a very long time
employees have leverage
for those of us who want to stay in the
industry
that means we can be a little bit more
picky and that we can spend a little bit
more time to find a good fit it also
means that we can and actually we have
to
take this opportunity to hold businesses
accountable i think companies are going
to have to compete for good talent and i
think some of the things that's going to
make certain companies stand out are
things like good work-life balance
flexibility
good office culture
fair pay and benefits
positive missions and smart business
strategies proper staffing or even
overstaffing to make sure that it's not
the end of the world when somebody quits
checking in regularly with the employees
and conducting
stay interviews rather than exit
interviews
at which point it's already too late i
think we should take some time to ask
what we really want
and how can we create situations that's
gonna help us get that i think i realize
in these past few years that i
physically can't go in
day in and day out doing something that
i hate
i mean work is work
and
no work is perfect i'm not saying that
but for the majority of the times
i want to be doing something that i find
meaningful and enjoyable i also realize
that i need flexibility
like when i have an appointment i don't
want to have to ask permission to go
i just want there to be trust and
transparency
and
actually that's not really something you
can demand from your employer
you have to gain that trust you need to
prove that you can be trusted
and if your employer's values align with
yours then that's going to give you more
freedom and control
but you have to kind of make the first
move and create that situation it also
means that maybe
we can take a little bit more time to
find the right fit rather than just like
taking the very first offer that comes
through the door there's been a lot of
issues with
the architecture industry
but a part of the problem is
and it always has been
us
and it's because a lot of us just put up
with the bad conditions
and when we do this
this lowers the standard for everyone in
the industry
and also for the generation after us
so we need to understand the value that
we can bring and we need to ask for it
because you're never gonna get it if you
don't ask for it
and if they say no
you can move on
knowing that you tried i also just want
to add that
i think it's always better to try to fix
the problem
where you're at
rather than just quitting and leaving
because that doesn't really give your
employers the opportunity to fix their
mistakes and learn from that especially
for architects i'm kind of always an
advocate for like sticking with your
project from start to finish
because that's such a valuable
experience
anyways whether you already quit your
job or whether you're planning on
quitting your job or whether you're
planning on staying put
i think we can all take this as an
opportunity to reflect on what brings us
meaning and happiness
and if there's one thing i've learned
from these past few years is that
reflection and journaling on even the
most mundane things can really really
transform the way you see things and it
can help you make good decisions
anyways i would really love to hear your
thoughts on this what has your work
experience been like these past few
years has your relationship to work
changed at all i also wanted to know
i know i make content mostly about
architecture
but since starting the youtube channel
i've been
reading a lot about business and
entrepreneurship in general
and i just wanted to get a sense of how
many of you would be interested in the
topic of business or like side hustles
or even youtube
um because i think
having started this thing while having a
full-time job
i have gained some insights that i think
you would find valuable
let me know in the comments also i have
one more announcement i will be doing a
monthly newsletter it will go out every
last saturday of the month
and i'll just be sharing updates on the
channel updates on things that i found
things that i learned things that i read
like new insights or experiences
so if you are interested in signing up
i'll leave the link below if you enjoyed
this video please give me a thumbs up
and if you're not subscribed already
please subscribe and hit the bell so
that you can get notifications every
time i make a new video i'm gonna start
having a more regular posting schedule
so keep an eye out for that
[Music]
you